hallo leute in unserem video heute geht
es um ein thema mit dem viele von euch
probleme haben im deutschen nämlich den
deutschen plural
im deutschen gibt es sieben reguläre
plural formen das problem ist jedoch
dass es von all diesen formen und regeln
ausnahmen gibt zum beispiel gibt es eine
regel dass 90 prozent aller femininen
wörter am ende oder im plural die endung
en bekommen zum beispiel die frau die
faulen die frage die fragen die zeit die
zeiten aber es gibt zum beispiel die
stadt die städte es gibt also viele
ausnahmen und wie lernt man den plural
am besten zum einen sollte tier
tatsächlich die regeln einmal lernen die
stellen wir euch in diesem video vor
und zum anderen müsst ihr einfach üben
üben üben und das ist manchmal natürlich
nervig und wir haben aber eine kleine
idee oder ein vorschlag für euch wie ihr
das möglichst erfolgreich und effizient
tun könnt wie ihr wisst haben wir eine
app entwickelt schon vor allem in der
zeit die heißt sie länger und in dieser
app entwickeln wir auch immer wieder
neue funktionen und eine funktion die
viele von euch schon oft angefragt haben
ist ein plural trainer und den haben wir
jetzt gebaut germany hat daran die
letzten wochen gearbeitet und wir freuen
uns den euch heute vorzustellen und
dafür haben wir auch einen gast
eingeladen
wir haben heute besuch von danny danny
ist vor kurzem nach berlin gezogen und
lernt schon seit ein paar monaten
deutsch und danny ist jetzt die erste
die unser flug als reiner testen wird
und sie ist auch schon eine aktive
nutzerin von c bank und wir haben uns
eigentlich dadurch kennen gelernt dass
danny uns immer wieder feedback
geschrieben hat und jetzt haben wir uns
persönlich kennengelernt
denn die bist du bereit und ihr zuhause
ihr könnt auch mitmachen ihr könnt mit
raten und dann später gucken wie viele
habt ihr richtig und zwischendurch
werben wir euch die regeln zu diesen
ganzen pluralen erklären fehler
ich werde fehler machen also bereich
geht dieser woche dann ist ein paar
recht gesagt wie viele viele fehler
machen aber du hast du es richtig
gemacht da gelang für die meisten
maskulinen wörter die auf e nl und er
enden haben keine änderung im plural der
fehler die fehler die emotionen die
emotionen ok kindheit die kindheit
kindheit die kindheit 90 prozent aller
femininen wörter haben einen plural der
mit en endet die emotionen die emotionen
die kindheit die kindheiten also immer
wenn du ein wort falsch gemacht hast
siehst du danach die richtige antwort
und auch die regel in dem plural trainer
durch die die ok gibt wird die 15 teams
ein schwieriges wort die ja ja ich kann
nichts versprechen aber du kannst ihn
perfekt okay die das brötchen die
brötchen brötchen aber du machst das
fast perfekt die meisten neutrum wörter
die auf zehn oder line enden haben im
plural keine veränderung zum beispiel
das brötchen die brötchen und die
meisten neutrum wörter die diese
änderungen nicht haben haben im plural
ein einfaches e
zum beispiel das angebot die angebote
die stadt
perfekt lehnwörter aus anderen sprachen
bekommen meistens einen es am ende
der chat die jets vogel die vögel
du weißt alles bei dem wort fehler haben
wir gelernt dass die meisten maskulinen
wörter die aus nhl und enden im plural
keine veränderung haben und hier ist
tatsächlich eine ausnahme davon
der vogel die vögel auto die auto auto
ist auch ein lehnwort gleichzeitig endet
es auf einem und die meisten wörter die
auf einem ohr oder enden bekommen auch
wenn es am ende zum beispiel der opa die
opas die oma die omas di carli die
careys abbruch die bücher einige neue
wörter bekommen im plural die endung und
einen umlaut das buch die bücher das ist
auch eine reguläre form
sie ist allerdings nicht so häufig wie
die endung ausstellung durch die
ausstellung ist wie ihr schon gehört
habt bekommen 90 prozent aller femininen
wörter die endung en die ausstellung die
ausstellungen kopf die kupfer die
meisten maskulinen wörter die nicht auf
e mol und enden bekommen eine im plural
und viele von diesen auch noch einen
umlaut der kopf die köpfe und die kinder
jahrhundert die hunde einsilbige
feminine und maskuline wörter bekommen
oft ein e und einen umlaut im plural zum
beispiel die nacht die nächte der hund
ist jedoch eine ausnahme es heißt der
hund die hunde und das ist ein wort was
janisch auch manchmal noch falsch macht
er sagt auch manchmal noch
finde aber es heißt kunde also das ist
ein schwieriges wort danke ok monika die
monitor der monitor die monitore
wie ihr schon gehört habe bekommen die
meisten maskulinen wörter die nicht auf
e ler und en ende mai nähe im plural der
monitor die monitore
jetzt kannst du noch mal deine fehler
verbessern hin siehst du noch mal die
alten videos die du falsch gemacht hast
okay wir natürlich noch ja ja ja die
kindheit und die hunde und die monitore
du bist ja du bist ja also alle haben
gewusst es schon alles und 7 vorjahr
nämlich bevor er diesen test gemacht
haben und sie kannte die wörter nicht
und sie hat vorher gesagt dass sie angst
hat alles falsch zu machen
und ja du hast ein bisschen dich unter
deinem wert verkauft sagt man auch
deutsch du hast gedacht oder uns gesagt
dass du ganz schlecht ist aber du bist
nicht schlecht ein deutsches der hammer
danke für siedlung und wie lange lernst
du schon länger mit ziegler also also
vier oder fünf monate
ja das ist lange und benutzte das jeden
tag oder ja ich versuche ja ja ja ich
muss ja der tag ja jeden tag üben so ist
das wenn man deutschland aber manchmal
macht es ja auch spaß sagt zum beispiel
jetzt wenn du so einen guten test
gemacht hat ja danke danny dass du
mitgemacht hast ja ja danke danke dass
du warst und jetzt seid ihr dran wir
wollen von euch wissen wie viele wörter
hättet ihr richtig bei diesem test
schreibt uns mal hier unten denn die
hatte 75 richtig wie viel war es bei
euch und natürlich könnt ihr jetzt den
plural trainer
auch selber testen und zwar weniger auf
den link klickt und hier unten in der
beschreibung
da ist der link dankeschön fürs
zuschauen und bis bald